Priscilla and Randolph have been
treating coronavirus patients on the
front line even though they know their
ethnicities mean they're at greater risk
of dying from Kovac 19 economy really
worried I was really scared I'm gonna
die in the thing is if I die how is it
going to happen what was gonna happen he
said that my parents are going to have
to pay for my body to come it I mean it
was it was all die I didn't know what to
think it was all very difficult with the
knowledge black Asian and ethnic
minority health care workers need to be
protected NHS employers have now created
a point base system that determines the
risk to a member of staff the guidance
means managers can remove people from
the front line and even ask them to work
from home if they're deemed high risk
65% of all NHS workers who have died
from Kovac 19 are from a black Asian or
minority ethnic background this new set
of guidelines hope to throw a protective
ring around such workers and stop more
of them from becoming infected but with
so many having lost their lives
is this not all a bit too late this
guidance is long overdue and what's
important now from this moment onwards
is that we see that sees implemented in
reality so that health care workers from
ABI AME origin who are at higher risk
and all other work workers who are at
higher risk are given an assessment and
given them necessary protections to
prevent them becoming infected and
seriously ill some hospitals like East
Surrey made changes early on they
already assessed the needs of vulnerable
staff and have redeployed some it hasn't
impacted on patient safety but it's
given those staff who have those
concerns or higher risk factors the
opportunity to be in a less risk area
here be AME employees share concerns and
ideas like introducing accessible
instructions on hygiene for those who
don't have English as a first language
another trust is also supplying vitamin
D free
charge to star from diverse backgrounds
to help bolster their immune systems I'm
happier now I know there I'm following
the guidelines and I'm well supported
and half the PP other sectors like
Transport which traditionally have a
high proportion of ethnic minority staff
are in talks with unions to roll out
similar measures we've known for a while
that this group is at greater risk and
the challenge now is to protect them
Asha here in Agra Sky News